débutons ce matin nous avons deux
auditions nous débutants avec l'audition
de Monsieur Bernard Benhamou aujourd'hui
secrétaire général de l'Institut de la
souveraineté numérique dans de
précédentes fonctions vous avez
également été délégué un terminal aux
usages de l'Internet auprès du ministère
de la recherche et du ministère de
l'Économie numérique ainsi que
conseiller de la délégation française au
sommet des Nations Unies sur la société
de l'information le Sénat est positionné
depuis plusieurs années en faveur d'une
plus grande souveraineté numérique
européenne quand je dis le Sénat c'est
même certains collègues et leur travail
en particulier pas loin de moi
il y a eu la commission d'enquête sur la
souveraineté numérique de 2019 ou encore
le rapport récent de la commission des
affaires économiques sur la souveraineté
aujourd'hui c'est bien la question
TikTok précisément qui nous intéresse et
les leçons que nous pourrions en tirer
pour renforcer notre souveraineté
numérique je mets tout ça avec plein de
guillemets qu'est-ce que ça recouvre
derrière l'aspect effectif ou pas de
tout ça que soit du point de vue du
droit des infrastructures ou encore des
logiciels nous interrogeons notamment
sur la capacité de Tik Tok et de la
Chine à transférer et accéder aux
informations des utilisateurs européens
même si ces données se sont stockées
dans des centres de données qui soient
européens ou qu'ils soient
nord-américains la Chine se dote en
effet à l'image des États-Unis d'un
arsenal juridique extraterritorial le
plus en plus offensif pour ne pas dire
agressif je le dis pour les deux qui
constituent un défi sur le chemin de
notre souveraineté donc avant de vous
laisser la parole pour un exposé
luminaire d'une quinzaine de minutes si
vous voulez bien parce qu'on a eu une
heure à passer ensemble je dois procéder
au formalités d'usage et vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant la
commission d'enquête est passible des
peines prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et
15 du code pénal et je vous invite à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure je le
jure je vous remercie nous vous écoutons
merci à vous tous merci effectivement de
m'avoir convié assez travaux sur un
sujet effectivement qui apparaît
maintenant au niveau international comme
un sujet majeur
face effectivement à ce que l'on
pourrait appeler le début d'une guerre
froide technologique sinon américaine et
avec des conséquences qui il faudra
évaluer dans le dans le temps alors déjà
revenons sur l'objet lui-même il y a
beaucoup de discussions sur Tik Tok sur
ce qu'il est ce qu'est ce réseau social
se réseau ou en tout cas peu importe la
dénomination qu'on lui donne l'important
étant de savoir comment ils fonctionnent
il y a eu toute une série de débats
auxquels certains de nous on était
associé ces derniers temps sur le fait
de savoir si le fait que contrairement à
Twitter contrairement à Facebook il va
nous repose pas sur uniquement sur ce
qu'on appelle un grave social je suis
désolé de rentrer d'emblée dans les dans
les considérations techniques
c'est-à-dire en clair le fait
d'associer des personnes de manière à
savoir quelles sont effectivement les
groupes de personnes avec lesquels on
interagit et certains ont dit non il ne
repose que sur un graphe d'intérêt en
fait la véritable dénomination qui est
admise désormais dans la communauté des
chercheurs c'est le graphe social
d'intérêt ou en anglais socio-interest
graph c'est à dire qu'en fait il mêle
les deux
il mêle à la fois la dimension d'analyse
des goûts personnels en fonction
effectivement des vidéos que vous
regardez mais aussi effectivement des
interactions que vous pouvez avoir avec
des gens dont vous savez qu'ils vont
diffuser des vidéos etc etc donc en fait
c'est un panachage de deux modèles
donc le fait de dire comme ça a pu être
dit y compris par des autorités de notre
gouvernement que ce n'est pas aussi
toxique en apparence que ne le serait
les autres réseaux sociaux du fait même
de la structure d'analyse des données
non non ça ce n'est pas juste donc ça
c'est un premier point de surcroît
puisque vous posiez la question d'emblée
des données il faut comprendre
effectivement que quel que soit les
précautions que l'on prend y compris
donc le projet Texas aux États-Unis donc
l'hébergement local de la même manière
effectivement c'est la manière dont les
données avant que de parler
effectivement de l'exploitation
gouvernementale qui peut être faite de
ces données c'est la manière de ces
données vont être analysées jusque dans
la plus fine
je dirais dans le plus intime des
détails de la personne qui peuvent être
inquiétantes je donnerai effectivement
je vous conseillerais effectivement les
éléments que je vais citer aujourd'hui
il y a un article assez intéressant qui
est apparu il y a quelques temps déjà en
2018 dans New York Times qui faisait
état des brevets plus alors je traduis
les plus flippants creepy en anglais
elle est plus flippants qui avaient pu
déposer Facebook et on y voyait toute
une série de brevets sur l'analyse
comportementale le suivi en temps réel
l'analyse des goûts le rapprochement
entre les personnes et leur consommation
audiovisuelle on voit bien effectivement
que dans ce cas-là parce qu'on a un
niveau de transparence du fait des
brevets déposés on voyait bien
effectivement vers quoi ça pouvait mener
c'est à dire pas simplement
l'orientation vers une action de
recommandation publicitaire ce qui est
des facto le métier de Facebook mais
bien effectivement la possibilité de de
percevoir le plus intime très de
caractère pour être en mesure
d'interagir voire d'orienter de
manipuler diront certains et donc on
voit bien que c'est ce genre de
préoccupation qui doit nous dire nous
intéresser aujourd'hui et ne pas
considérer effectivement que cette
neutre que de pouvoir percevoir autant
de données y compris des données
biométriques des données émotionnelles
j'y reviendrai c'est à dire que aussi
bien l'empreinte vocale que l'empreinte
faciale peuvent être effectivement
captées et ça fait partie des
autorisations que ceux que se permet
effectivement Tik Tok aujourd'hui et on
voit bien que ça peut avoir des
répercussions sur l'analyse
comportementale de manière importante de
manière générale puisqu'il s'agit d'une
société chinoise
je citerai un autre grand spécialiste
des technologies qui est chinois et qui
a beaucoup travaillé effectivement sur
les technologies d'intelligence
artificielle c'est un certain cas il
folie qui avait une formule amusante qui
disait l'Ouest a développé ses
innovations à partir de rien nous nous
allons les développer à partir de vous
c'est-à-dire que pour la Chine est
totalement normal
d'utiliser entre guillemets ça s'est vu
avec Alibaba ça s'est vu avec d'autres
sociétés qui ont utilisé des modèles
économiques existants pour essayer
effectivement de développer dans un dans
je dirais dans un climat beaucoup plus
protégé protectionniste évidemment dans
le cas chinois
leur même technologie la particularité
c'est qu'effectivement certains ont pu
remarquer le départ foudroyants de
TikTok en termes de nombre d'abonnés ou
en tout cas d'utilisateurs on voit bien
effectivement que là il y a la volonté
d'utiliser et de développer
effectivement de faire de dériver de
modèles existants pour créer ses propres
technologies avec les risques dont on va
reparler un autre point important
puisqu'on parle beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle à l'heure actuelle c'est
l'actualité technologique du moment
j'aimerais vous rappeler là aussi en
lien avec les questions de souveraineté
un événement qui s'est produit il y a
quelques temps à savoir le piratage des
serveurs Microsoft Exchange alors vous
pouvez vous dire
quel rapport les serveurs en question
n'ont pas été piratés comme on le
pensait au départ à des fins
d'espionnage simple des sociétés et je
précise sa représenter plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'entreprises dans
le monde mais on a pu tracer en tout cas
les autorités américaines ont pu tracer
la chose et même les chercheurs ont pu
tracer la chose depuis la Chine et le
but était c'est là où ça devient
intéressant non pas d'espionner ces
sociétés pour
extraire quelques données à caractère
effectivement stratégique etc non
c'était pour alimenter les moteurs
d'intelligence artificielle chinois de
manière à ce qu'ils deviennent meilleurs
que leurs équivalents américains ou
européens parce qu'on comme on le sait
l'intelligence artificielle se nourrit
de donner et donc avoir des données
structurées de centaines de milliers
voire de millions d'entreprises étaient
une chose particulièrement stratégique
pour développer justement des solutions
alternatives et quoi de plus intéressant
pour une société effectivement chinoise
que de pouvoir extraire des données sur
l'ensemble des citoyens de la planète en
particulier dans les pays développés
mais pas que et je rappellerai
d'ailleurs que Tik Tok n'est pas le même
en Chine Tik Tok s’appelle Douilly in en
Chine et qu'il est beaucoup plus orienté
vers l'éducation
je veux dire les sciences économiques la
formation que le loisir tel que nous
pouvons le connaître ici et donc par
définition il faut comprendre que les
données recueillies sont
valorisables à plusieurs niveaux
différents le premier niveau c'est le
niveau publicitaire c'est le modèle
économique dont on pourra parler qui est
assez toxique par rapport à ces sociétés
le deuxième niveau est aussi un niveau
stratégique pour développer justement
d'autres technologies donc ça c'est un
point important de surcroît puisqu'on a
souvent eu l'occasion de le dire vous
citiez en introduction monsieur le
Président vous citiez le fait
effectivement de l'extraterritorialité
du droit en particulier chinois mais
aussi américain puisqu'on en a souvent
parlé avec la loi fizza plus encore que
que la loi ficelle la plus la plus
secrète et possiblement la plus
intrusive et quasiment inévitable pour
les sociétés en question de la même
manière pour les sociétés chinoises
refusaient comme ça a été dit par le
gouvernement chinois lui-même en disant
nous ne prendrons pas nous ne
recueillerons pas les données en
provenance de Tik Tok d'abord un c'est
impossible de le promettre de les
sociétés on l'a vu pour nous
occidentaux les sociétés y compris
américaines qui disent ça a été le cas
de Microsoft nous nous engageons à ne
pas confier
gouvernement américain des données si
elles concernent les utilisateurs
européens tout simplement ils ne le
peuvent pas la loi leur interdit de
prendre ce genre d'engagement parce que
lorsque la NSA pour ne citer qu'elle va
effectivement demander des données à
telle ou telle société aucune d'entre
elles et pour en avoir parlé avec les
responsables de plus haut niveau de ces
sociétés qui s'agissent de Facebook de
Microsoft ou d'autres ne peut refuser et
je le précise sous peine de sanction
lourdes pour ceux qui s'y risqueraient
de prison fédérale de plusieurs années
de prison fédérale donc on est là dans
une sorte de jeu d'hypocrisie qui est
quand même assez inquiétant donc ça
c'est une première chose donc vu vu de
la Chine au vu effectivement de sa
volonté
évidente de développer un arsenal
technologique de niveau équivalent voir
supérieur à celui des Etats-Unis d'où on
y reviendra cette guerre froide sinon
américaine avec cet embargo sur les
technologies clés à savoir
supercalculateurs processeur de haut
niveau plus évidemment intelligence
artificielle on voit bien effectivement
que pour eux un élément stratégique dans
tous les sens du terme y compris je
dirais un immense stratégique de
contrôle politique des populations parce
que quand vous connaissez dans la dans
la sphère la plus intime pas plusieurs
entendez bien dizaines de milliers de
paramètres par individus c'est pas vous
savez les questionnaires dans le temps
âge sexe localisation professionnelle
non on est là dans l'ultra précision sur
effectivement chaque levier que l'on
peut utiliser sur un individu par
définition ne pas les utiliser j'ai eu
l'occasion de le confier à des
journalistes il y a peu ne pas utiliser
constituer de la part des services
chinois une sorte de faute
professionnelle et par définition on
voit je vous en prie votre citation est
commence à être connue à faire le tour
quand vous avez déjà dit que Bernard
Benamou dit que ça serait une faute
professionnelle sachez que ça fait le
tour dans beaucoup de sphères qui
s'intéressent au sujet déposé le droit
d'auteur pour les faire respecter sur
Tik Tok je ne suis pas à ce point
regardant sur mes droits d'auteur mais
mais des facto je vais vous dire une
chose c'est un ami en fait c'est une
citation dérivée de celle d'un ami qui
travaillait pour à l'époque en tant que
cryptographe pour Google
et qui m'avait parlé à l'époque de la
blockchain vous savez donc c'est cette
technologie décrypte en particulier des
crypto-monnaies une pas que et qui
m'avait dit l'algorithme de sécurité
pour les plus techniciens d'entre nous
et Sacha 256 peu importe
a été élaboré par la NSA et il m'a dit
s'ils n'ont pas installé de porte
dérobées dedans c'est qu'ils font mal
leur travail
par définition ce qui est vrai à l'est
est vrai à l'ouest et donc ne pas
considérer comme argent comptant les
déclarations de bonne volonté des uns et
des autres
je rappellerai de surcroît pour ceux
d'entre eux parce que ceux qui sont
parfois tentés de renvoyer nos ados
américains Chine par rapport à cela
ce n'est en rien comparable et je sais
que je me suis ici même dans ces murs et
à de très nombreuses reprises prononcées
contre effectivement les excès de de
complaisance par rapport à certaines
déclarations ou certaines technologies
ou certains acteurs dans ce domaine en
particulier aux Etats-Unis
mais ce qui se passe vis-à-vis de la
Chine n'a rien à voir nous intéresse
stratégiques sont totalement différents
de surcroît les valeurs que souhaitent
non pas simplement
faire prévaloir les autorités chinoises
mais éteindre au sein de leur pays et à
l'international sont évidemment les
nôtres ou pour le dire autrement pour
ceux d'entre vous que la chose
intéressent
il y a effectivement un document qui
avait été diffusé dans le cadre du Parti
communiste chinois donc de plus hautes
instances ça peut être document numéro 9
qui je cite avec comme but d'éradiquer
explicitement la démocratie
constitutionnelle la séparation des
pouvoirs le principe universel des
droits de l'homme et des libertés
fondamentales la promotion de la liberté
civile le néolibéralisme économique
évidemment le nihilisme historique
c'est-à-dire toute pensée critique qui
réfute la valeur scientifique de la
pensée de Mao donc par définition nous
ne pouvons pas avoir une attitude
symétrique nous ne pouvons pas et donc
c'est important d'y revenir je reviens à
l'instant sur le modèle économique de
Tik Tok
comme la plupart des réseaux sociaux à
l'heure actuelle il repose sur l'analyse
des données et sur un modèle qui est
comme on dit là aussi excusez-moi pour
l'anglicisme data centric c'est-à-dire
centrer sur l'utilisation des données
des personnes mais qui est amplifié par
la volonté d'en faire un outil de
contrôle politique par les autorités
chinoises parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est que quand on
dispose de cette possibilité on a la
possibilité de
dévasser d'éradiquer toute forme de
contestation à l'intérieur d'un pays
c'est-à-dire de pardon de détecter au
plus tôt toute forme de contestation de
remise en cause de certaines positions
de certaines politiques publiques pour
être en mesure effectivement de détecter
et de sanctionner les personnes c'est le
principe en Chine de ce qu'on appelle le
Crédit social qui est une chose
parfaitement effrayante parfaitement
orwellienne une notation dont qui
concerne la totalité des 1,4 milliards
de chinois et qui a pour but de noter
non seulement leur comportement
financier mais aussi leur justement
personnel politique sociale
dans l'ensemble des activités des
personnes qui donnent lieu
à effectivement dès que vous prenez la
parole sur un réseau social pour dire
des choses qui ne vont pas effectivement
dans les lignes telles que les dictée
par le parti qui donne lieu
effectivement à des sanctions puisque
lorsque le crédit la note de crédit
social est trop basse la personne la
plus l'occasion n'a plus le droit de
voyager en train en avion on a pu accès
à des crédits financiers n'a pu accès à
des promotions dans le cadre de son
travail devient un véritable paria les
concepteurs de ce système qui sont
d'ailleurs beaucoup appuyés sur Alibaba
quand ils l'ont fait ont eu l'occasion
de dire notre objectif est clair il faut
que les personnes qui sont sanctionnées
dans le cadre du Crédit Social
deviennent des parias au sein de la
société chinoise
donc par définition il faut il faut
avoir en tête que nous sommes la face à
un modèle qui est radicalement différent
d'une autre et donc ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas faire de la cynophobie comme
parfois on l'entend que de le dire c'est
de constater une orientation stratégique
et politique et donc que Tik Tok soit
contraint dans tous les sens du terme
par cette volonté politique est une
évidence et donc le fait de ne pas se
poser la question et dangereux je
rappellerai d'ailleurs un article récent
paru dans le monde il y a quelques temps
en Chine ce qu'on parlait de
l'intelligence artificielle en Chine
même les robots conversationnels doivent
être diapason des valeurs socialistes
c'est-à-dire qu'il a été rappelé
récemment que toutes ces sociétés dont
on peut rappeler qu'elle dispose
quasiment toutes d'une antenne du Parti
communiste chinois donc du PCC dans leur
locaux c'est le cas de la plupart de ces
grandes entreprises elles doivent
effectivement aussi promouvoires par
définition les orientations politiques
et non pas simplement économiques du
régime et quand elle ne le font pas et
on l'a vu avec Alibaba que je leur
responsable sont quasiment mis en
résidence surveillée exilés c'est le cas
de Jacquemin maintenant qui
effectivement s'est réfugiés au Japon
pendant un temps et a été dépossédé la
société qu'il avait créé là-bas de façon
tout à fait claire c'est à dire qu'on a
évincé globalement de l'ensemble des
activités de surcroît il faut rappeler
l'opacité puisque je parle on évoquait
tout à l'heure les les
protestations de bonne foi que peuvent
émettre les autorités chinoises dans ces
domaines mais l'opacité quant au
fonctionnement des systèmes et donc de
l'algorithme des algorithmes qui font
fonctionner Tik Tok et complète et que
imaginez ce qui a été dit par exemple
aux États-Unis que sous prétexte que les
données soient hébergées là-bas que des
sociétés pourraient avoir accès au code
et pourraient effectivement l'audité le
cas échéant et ça a été évoqué pour
Oracle qui était censé travailler avec
un TikTok aux États-Unis c'est un leurre
c'est un leurre et on a bien vu au
niveau nous européen de la Commission
européenne que même dans un cadre
européen lorsqu'il a été question par
exemple de Microsoft dans le cadre d'une
action antitrust sur Windows et
confusion avec Internet Explorer
Microsoft a systématiquement refusé de
transférer ses codes sources à la
Commission européenne en disant avec un
argument extraordinaire en disant nous
ne les avons plus à tellement évolué de
plus que nous ne pouvons pas ce qui est
remarquable nous ne pouvons pas vous les
transmettre
donc pas par définition il faut bien
comprendre effectivement que lorsque
l'on réfléchit à TikTok on doit
réfléchir à une situation stratégique à
une situation à la fois technique mais
aussi technologique et politique qui est
effectivement radicalement différente
et je rappellerai d'ailleurs puisqu'on
évoquait la capacité à percevoir toutes
sortes de données puisque l'application
est capable d'analyser la manière dont
vous interagissez avec elle vos
habitudes et vous savez on est on est
capable aujourd'hui de reconnaître une
personne à la manière qu'elle a de taper
sur un clavier
et oui mieux encore on est capable de
reconnaître une personne à manière
qu'elle a de marcher avec les différents
capteurs d'accélération du téléphone
donc par définition on va très très loin
et je vais vous citer je vais pas être
trop long parce que je prépare à vos
questions aussi un propos qui a été tenu
dans
l'historien
à propos du contrôle par les émotions il
disait il est important de se rappeler
que colère joie ennui amour sont aussi
des phénomènes biologiques comme la
fièvre et la toux la technologie qui
identifie la toux pourrait également
identifier les rires si entreprises et
gouvernement commence à collecter nos
données biométriques en masse il
pourrait mieux nous connaître que nous
nous connaissons nous-mêmes et il
pourrait non seulement prédire nos
sentiments nos sentiments mais aussi les
manipuler et nous vend tout ce qu'ils
veulent qu'il s'agisse d'un produit ou
d'un politicien la surveillance
biométrique ferait ressembler le
piratage des données de Cambridge
Analytica à des outils de l'âge de
pierre
donc vous voyez pas par définition il
faut bien comprendre aujourd'hui c'est
le point sur lequel je souhaiterais
terminer que dans le de manière générale
on a sous-estimé l'usage qui pouvait
être faite ses données à des fins de
contrôle des individus des populations
et je précise que c'est l'obsession
permanente de régime autoritaire que de
contrôler leur population par définition
et on a sous-estimé l'impact que ça
pouvait avoir on l'a vu avec Cambridge
un étiquette puisque c'était cité qui a
effectivement joué un rôle dont certains
pensent qu'il a été important dans
l'élection de Donald Trump donc en 2016
par définition on voit bien
effectivement que nous devons nous poser
la question de savoir si l'extraction
des données c'est comme ça qu'on dit
c'est à dire le fait de voir extraire de
plus en plus de données sur les
individus doit être poursuivi et si ces
modèles et nous sommes quelques-uns à le
penser ne sont pas devenus à ce point
toxique ils doivent être remises en
cause ces modèles économiques sont
effectivement des modèles qui qui
incitent à une forme effectivement non
seulement de dissémination sauvage des
données on l'a vu avec ce qu'on appelle
les courtiers en données les Data
brokers mais mais globalement
effectivement je crois que
l'affrontement qui devra nous agiter
dans les temps à venir en Europe sur un
affrontement entre différents types de
valeurs mais aussi différents types de
modèles économiques et je crois
effectivement et on le voit aujourd'hui
avec le débat autour de l'intelligence
artificielle et le fait de savoir si on
va pas aller davantage vers des systèmes
d'abonnement
souscription plutôt que des systèmes
effectivement de d'apparente gratuité
pour après effectivement alimenter des
systèmes de recueil de données je crois
que c'est extrêmement important et je
crois que c'est la dimension que l'on
sous-estime c'est-à-dire qu'on prend
comme un fait d'évidence comme un fait
de nature le fait effectivement que ce
modèle existe et qu'il doit être éternel
et bien non je pense effectivement qui
nous expose on l'a vu aux États-Unis
avec une quasi tentative de coup d'État
le 6 janvier qui avait été mené par des
gens qui pour beaucoup étaient
structurés autour de réseaux sociaux
comme facebook avec le les célèbres
cuana nous savaient avec le type avec
les cornes
dont ces mouvements extrémistes
n'existent que parce qu'ils ont pu se
regrouper du fait des affinités qu'on
leur a trouvé sur Facebook c'est à dire
pour employer le terme technique du
micro-ciblage du micro targeting au
travers effectivement de ce genre de
réseau et je précise que tous les
mouvements extrémistes
ont pu ont pu s'étoffer grâce à ce genre
de ciblage politique de publicité ciblée
et de et d'analyse effectivement des
comportements des personnes ou des
affinités des personnes et je terminerai
mais vraiment en citant une personne que
je ne cite jamais et avec laquelle je ne
suis que très très rarement en accord un
certain Vladimir Poutine qui disait
que le pays qui sera leader dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
dominera le monde
au départ vous voyez c'est un petit peu
une vision européenne ou occidentale au
centre je pensais qu'il parlait
d'armement d'économie non il parlait de
contrôle politique
et par définition lui qui est un
observateur acharné de ce qui se passe
en Chine c'est le Crédit Social c'est la
possibilité de de calmer d'étouffer
d'éradiquer toute forme de contestation
dans son pays qui l'intéresse pour
rester au pouvoir et donc il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est qu'il y a un
volet économique un volet technologique
mais aussi évidemment un volet
stratégique un volet politique à la
réflexion que nous devons avoir dans ces
domaines
bien merci pour cette introduction très
dense on va passer aux questions et pour
filer la métaphore
russe vous êtes cité Poutine donc
maintenant en fait c'est que faire
je j'inscris les collègues qui ont des
questions je vais en lancer une première
donc évidemment madame vous me fait
signe vous signalez un sur le sur le que
faire de Lénine monsieur
j'en lance une première est-ce que vous
avez est-ce que vous avez au sein de
votre institut de la souveraineté
numérique mener des travaux
spécifiques à Tik Tok ou est-ce que ce
que vous nous dites finalement c'est que
vous faites un croisement entre le la
question culturelle du du socialisme
chinois et du comportement de l'État et
du Parti communiste chinois que vous
croisez avec les possibilités techniques
offertes et donc ce que vous ce qui vous
inquiète c'est l'intentionnalité ou bien
vous avez pu on vous a remonté le fait
que telle personne a pu être manipulée
un peu comme je m'excuse toujours une
parenthèse que vous avez raconté me fait
penser un peu à la façon dont des
régimes autoritaires ont pu comme c'est
par exemple quand on sait comment Ramon
Mercader a été a été préparé pendant des
années etc comment on essaie de
manipuler tel ou telle personne
entourage tel ou tel autre peut-être
maintenant c'est puissance je ne sais
combien de milliards de fois est-ce
qu'on a des cas de personnes dont je
sais que on a regardé leur téléphone on
a scanner tout ça et on a su comment
comme on dit dans les services les
tamponner plus facilement parce qu'on
connaît leurs émotions leur centre
d'intérêt est-ce que vous avez ça avec
TikTok ou est-ce que vous faites une
analyse et un croisement et c'est une
analyse globale
micro
c'est bon
plusieurs cas de figure ont été révélés
dont un qui concernait des journalistes
dont on a suivi la géolocalisation de
manière continue à des fins précises et
à des femmes politiques puisqu'il
s'agissait de déterminer des fuites donc
on voit bien effectivement et je précise
que là c'était c'était un cauchemar pour
la communication
institutionnelle de TikTok puisqu'ils
ont dit tout le travail que nous faisons
pour essayer justement d'apparaître
comme respectueux des données etc est en
train d'être abattu par ce genre de
choses de surcroît il y a eu beaucoup de
cas qui ont été déterminés qui ont
d'ailleurs précipité l'interdiction près
des fonctionnaires américains des
fonctionnaires gouvernementaux puis
après effectivement en Europe au niveau
de la Commission européenne
effectivement d'analyses de la
géolocalisation alors la plupart des
réseaux sociaux utilisent la
géolocalisation mais voyez c'est
toujours le problème vous parlez
d'intentionnalité le problème c'est de
savoir dans quelle mesure le fait de
pouvoir disposer de la géolocalisation
quand il s'agit de Twitter ou de
Facebook est différent du fait de dis
la différence c'est que la transparence
que j'évoquais au tout départ avec les
brevets flippants de Facebook ça on y a
accès en Chine pas du tout et donc par
définition le degré de toxicité que peut
avoir cette société dans le cas de ces
activités c'est une chose qui nous est
pour l'instant inconnu que nous ne
pouvons que
très âgée ou imaginé mais par définition
des enquêtes commencent à avoir lieu sur
les types de contenus qui sont
disponibles pour auprès des uns des
autres mais du fait du caractère de
boîte noire c'était le nom d'ailleurs du
livre de Pascual la société boîte noire
le BlackBox Society par définition nous
sommes contraints par ce caractère de
boîte noire
il y a qu'un jour nos débats dans les
miss cycle portant sur l'intelligence
artificielle ont bien démontré ce par
quoi vous avez commencé à savoir que
nous sommes dans un début de guerre
technologique États-Unis Chine sur ces
sur ces questions et que la concurrence
est féroce il y a à la fois des volontés
de contrôle du devenir du du monde de la
société de la connaissance et de
l'économie
et il y a aussi forcément une
concurrence par rapport au au profit
personne n'a été dû d'ailleurs de
l'attitude d'Elon musk suscitant un
moratoire sur l'interjection
satyrusienne je crois qu'il était
davantage animé par des considérations
économiques que par des constellations
éthiques alors il a été mis en avant au
cours de ce débat que finalement l'Union
européenne avait le mérite pour une fois
de se positionner cheminement avec un
projet de règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle même si ce projet de
règlement sera peut-être imparfait
puisque c'est un sujet complexe
intelligence artificielle c'est source
de progrès mais en même temps de risque
pour savoir bien sûr
d'oser les mesures que nous prenons ils
s'articulent avec le DSA le DMA alors
par rapport justement à cette
réglementation vous avez dû
l'analyser est-ce que vous considérez
quand l'État les mesures proposées
permettent la protection du citoyen
européen utilisateur de ces plateformes
considérant les risques les hauts
risques que vous avez émis vous venez de
parler de boîte noire considérez-vous
je me suis fait une réponse en réalité
et en faire un rapport sur ce sujet mais
je voudrais entendre votre propre
analyse considérez-vous vous quand
l'État nous avons suffisamment axé en
somme à ces algorithmes pour vérifier
qu'ils n'ont pas potentiellement des
effets toxiques et et dangereux donc
ceci ma première question ma deuxième
question porte sur ce que vous avez dit
c'est à dire que nous ne pouvons pas
avoir une attitude symétrique par
rapport à ces plateformes chinoises et
par rapport aux plateformes américaines
ou tout autre type de plateformes au
demeurant alors il est vrai qu'on fait
la différence entre un état ami les
États-Unis mais il s'agit non pas de
l'État mais des sociétés qui disposent
de ces plateformes pour du profit ou des
témoins de notre sécurité et de l'autre
côté directement du Parti communiste
chinois vous l'avez expliqué mais malgré
tout Nathalie Loiseau devant notre
commission d'enquête rappelée à juste
titre la semaine dernière que les
plateformes américaines disposent de
failles
volontairement parfois constituée on l'a
vu dans l'affaire Cambridge a été cas et
le rôle qu'a joué Facebook avec
l'entreprise qui ont déjà été car pour
permettre les ingérences d'État
étrangers donc l'attitude que nous
devons avoir doit être ne croyez-vous
pas sévères exigeantes également de ce
côté là c'est la question que je
souhaitée aussi vous poser merci
pendant d'emblée oui sans aucune
hésitation nous devons être exigeants
par rapport à la totalité des acteurs et
ne pas donner l'impression effectivement
d'une complaisance sélective qui serait
la pire des réponses possibles donc par
définition oui vous le rappeliez j'ai
tenu à le rappeler aussi nous ne pouvons
pas
envisager vous savez en diplomation par
le dual containers
le double handigme en considérant que le
risque est le même des deux côtés non le
risque n'est pas le même des deux côtés
donc ça ça c'est un premier point pour
revenir effectivement sur la première
question sur les textes européens donc
Aya des DM1 DSA data acte aussi
je cite j'emprunterai puisque c'est la
thématique du jour j'emprunterai à la
sagesse chinoise pour essayer d'y
répondre je dirais que le diable sera
dans le détail on pourrait être précis
pour avoir beaucoup suivi et beaucoup
été dans des cas de négociation
internationales
tout sera dans l'exécution est-ce que
l'on peut considérer aujourd'hui que
Laia qui est encore effectivement à
précise et je sais effectivement les
travaux qu'il y a à l'heure actuelle
pour y intégrer justement les nouvelles
plateformes dites conversationnel
l'intelligence artificielle alors que la
chose n'apparaissait pas évident et que
les États-Unis freinent à l'évidence des
quatre fers et exerce toute leur
possibilité leur potentiel de lobbying
pour éviter que ce ne soit le cas en
utilisant ce refrain que nous
connaissons tellement bien sur le frein
à l'innovation que cela pourrait
représenter je relisais il y a pas très
longtemps les textes au début des années
2000 sur le fait il ne faut pas réguler
ces plateformes ce serait un frein
inacceptable à l'innovation et on sait
très bien que si on avait régulé sur les
données personnelles aux États-Unis
il y a 10 ans je dirais sous
l'administration Obama les scandales et
les risques majeurs auxquels le pays a
été soumis ne se serait pas produit
et donc par définition aujourd'hui vous
savez même des gens qui ont été dans la
machine politique américaine me le
disent avec un terme très clair ils
disent la Révolution la régulation de
ces domaines aurait dû avoir lieu depuis
longtemps mais on sait le lobbying force
né qui a lieu au niveau du congrès du
Sénat américain pour que ça n'ait pas
lieu de très nombreux sénateurs et
sénatrices ont eu l'occasion de rappeler
que il devrait y avoir une loi fédérale
sur les données personnelles aux
États-Unis depuis au moins 10 ans et
qu'elle n'a pas eu lieu du fait
effectivement d'une intervention et la
lobbying forcenait dans ce domaine donc
pour revenir effectivement sur la
question européenne ces textes sont
importants je crois que au-delà de
l'expression de nos valeurs et c'est un
point sur lequel vous savez je suis
parti auquel je suis particulièrement
sensible il ne faut pas apparaître comme
uniquement défensif vous savez beaucoup
d'acteurs internationaux perçoivent
l'Europe communiquement le pays de la
régulation la France
pour beaucoup de pays et historiquement
lié à cette notion de régulation c'est
bien mais ce n'est pas assez si nous
n'avons pas une politique industrielle
qui nous permette à l'échelle de l'État
à l'échelle européen de développer des
acteurs qui eux-mêmes seront justement
en accord avec ses principes et ses
valeurs que nous défendons d'où le
propos que je vous tenais sur les
modèles économiques toxiques pour au
fait pour être en mesure de développer
d'autres modèles économiques dans les
temps à venir dans la santé dans
l'éducation dans dans la protection
environnementale maîtrise de l'énergie
les transports etc si nous ne
développons pas nos acteurs toutes
volonté et j'en parle à des régulateurs
pour avoir beaucoup travaillé avec des
régulateurs à toute volonté politique
sera contournée toute volonté juridique
sera contournée il nous faut créer les
conditions économiques d'une existence
européenne qui ne soit pas qu'une
existence de consommateur dans tous les
sens du terme
nous sommes le premier la première
région mondiale de consommation
technologies d'un point de vue
économique nous ne produisons pas des
technologies effectivement équivalentes
à haut niveau on se réjouit trop souvent
et artificiellement de nos licornes de
quelques succès locaux nous n'avons pas
d'acteurs à mettre en face de ces grands
acteurs américains ou chinois face au
gafam face au batxh donc pour les
chinois il doit battansen Xiaomi Huawei
nous n'avons pas d'acteurs de même
taille
et donc par définition je dirais qu'une
volonté stratégique politique doit
passer par une politique industrielle
dont je me réjouis que notre excellent
commissaire européen Thierry Breton se
soit emparé au sein de la Commission
européenne il n'est que temps il n'est
que temps c'est à dire que ne plus être
naïf face aux protectionnisme forcenet
de nos interlocuteurs chinois mais aussi
évidemment pour une grande partie de nos
interrupteurs Américains ne pas ne pas
ne pas considérer que cette une vision
de l'ancien temps trop souvent qui suit
un militant dans ces domaines on dit ça
oui mais vous comprenez c'est un terme
suranné politique industriel non c'est
c'est de là qu'on peut naître des
technologies essentielles et je précise
il s'agit pas de refaire le minitel ou
de refaire effectivement le plan de
calcul non il s'agit d'accompagner
intelligemment les secteurs clés dont
celui-là c'est-à-dire les secteurs
stratégiques dont effectivement le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
au combien pour être en mesure
effectivement d'exister sur la scène
mondiale pour l'instant soyons clairs
nous avons un handicap majeur à pouvoir
exister autrement que par la régulation
merci beaucoup pour la clarté de votre
propos et le fait que votre institut
s'appelle de la souveraineté numérique
c'est déjà tout un problème tout un
programme pardon politique auquel
j'adhère tout à fait notamment dans sa
dimension industrielle comme vous l'avez
dit que et qu'on oublie souvent mais qui
est tout à fait fondamental moi je
voulais vous questionner sur justement
la législation que vient de prendre
l'Europe avec les deux réglement ce que
pourrait faire la France et vous avez
quasiment répondu à ma question en
disant que finalement c'est pas
tellement les les actes juridiques qui
comptent c'est la façon dont les États
en œuvre c'est-à-dire
aller jusqu'au bout pour imposer à ces
groupes de le respecter et de
transmettre ce qui ne font pas
aujourd'hui alors mon collègue a cité
à
quelqu'un vient du côté de la Russie moi
j'aimerais citer Napoléon qui disait que
que la guerre est un art simple et tout
d'exécution la politique c'est
exactement la même chose qui compte
c'est c'est l'exécution c'est comment on
va s'emparer de de de ces documents donc
je
vous ai parfaitement répondu à ma
question moi ce que ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est est-ce que finalement la
réponse juridique et potentiellement
politique elle n'est pas toujours en
retard par rapport à l'évolution à
l'évolution de la technologie est-ce
qu'on a la capacité dans ce domaine à à
jouer
un coup ou plusieurs coups en avance et
préparer déjà des évolutions
technologiques parce que on voit bien
qu'on réagisse systématiquement par par
contrecoup et parfois avec 5 ou 10 ans
de retard est-ce qu'on a pas de
possibilités de voir un petit peu plus
loin merci je profite de l'arrivée de
monsieur le rapporteur que je souhaite
non je vous en prie je vous en prie pour
dire que justement et sans vouloir
effectivement
dresser un compliment facile l'occasion
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui montre qu'on
est capable de s'en occuper quasiment en
temps réel c'est-à-dire au moment où la
question comment ça se posait donc
l'idée suivant laquelle les états
seraient nécessairement en retard par
rapport à aux technologies c'est une
idée commode pour certains
je crois que on peut établir des limites
sans
et n'y voyez là aussi aucun jeu de mots
sans brider l'innovation
le but c'est c'est pour les états et en
particulier pour les États européens de
faire ce qui a été fait en d'autres
temps c'est à dire d'effectuer des choix
stratégiques je citer les quelques
grands secteurs dont je pense qu'ils
sont essentiels pour nous la santé santé
connectés un domaine fondamental à tous
les points de vue économiques
stratégique politique philosophie à tous
les niveaux
c'est vrai aussi effectivement je l'ai
dit maîtrise environnementale maîtrise
de l'énergie
transport économie finance les
technologies financières sont un domaine
sur lequel les Américains nous
reconnaissent une expertise et
effectivement sur lequel il faudrait
insister et au lieu de faire du
saupoudrage là je vais parler en tant
qu' ancien technicien de cabinet au lieu
de faire du saupoudrage sur des dizaines
comme ça pu être fait vous avez 34
filiales industrielles qui avaient été
signalé en d'autres temps
il faut avoir le courage de dire
certaines filières sont stratégiques
pour nous et nous devons les aider tout
particulièrement c'est l'objet par
exemple de de la décision récente de la
commission sur les technologies zéro
carbone qui ont été aidés
particulièrement et qui devront faire
l'objet d'une attention particulière
dans les temps à venir
je sais je sais dites-vous non plus plus
important encore puisque nous nous
situons en plus d'être dans une guerre
froide sinon américaine technologique
nous situons aussi dans un climat de
sécurité internationale très différent
de celui ne serait-ce qu'il y a 2 ans et
je maintiens j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
dans une dans un article pour qui
apparaître dans la revue de la
Documentation française
je maintiens que là-dessus
l'opportunité que constitue le fait de
remuscler si vous me permettez
l'expression les budgets militaires dont
on sait à quel point ils ont été
stratégiques pour les développements
technologiques aux États-Unis vous avez
la très remarquable économiste
italo-américaine Mariana mazukato qui
dit il y a pas une seule des
technologies clés de l'iPhone qui n'est
pas été développée par la commande
fédérale américaine et en particulier
militaire pourrait-on ajouter donc le
DARPA internet GPS l'intelligence
artificielle qui a beaucoup été
développée les interfaces
réalité augmentée réalité virtuelle tout
ça a d'abord été développé sous climat
militaire nous avons la possibilité
alors je sais que la LPM en est encore
stade infra mais il faut établir la
capacité effectivement pour ces
technologies militaires de participer au
développement technologies civile plus
encore que ça n'a été fait jusqu'à
présent et évidemment et j'insisterai
j'ai eu l'occasion de le redire encore
récemment dans un dans une dans un texte
qui a été d'ailleurs cosigné par de
nombreux sénateurs j'en suis ravi se
manifeste pour une nouvelle ambition
numérique avec la plupart des acteurs de
la sécurité de l'Internet français
européen il nous faut développer un
Small Business actif français européen
dans ces domaines pour aider nos
entreprises à se développer aussi par la
commande publique ce que l'on a négligé
volontairement d'une manière quasi
idéologique en disant vous comprenez ça
contrevient aux lois ou en tout cas aux
actions et à la philosophie de Bruxelles
en matière de marché libre et non fossés
ce qui est une absurdité et donc il nous
faut effectivement faire ce que les
Américains ont fait je le précise depuis
1953 ce n'est pas une chose récente le
small businessact pour effectivement
être en mesure de d'avoir des acteurs
qui puissent se développer avec des
clients ce qui a été dit par un de vos
collègues parlementaires cela tombe qui
disait un euro d'achat c'est 7 euros de
subvention en termes d'impact sur le
modèle économique d'une société
et donc par définition au lieu de
saupoudrer de l'argent il faut aider à
faire que la main la main prescriptive
prescriptrice de l'État soit plus au
service effectivement nos activités
économiques dans ces domaines
d'autres interventions
à ce stade écoutez moi j'en
aurais bien quelques-unes qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du
de cette vague puisque vous êtes à la
fois
analyse des temps entre le technique
profond et le politique est-ce que vous
pensez de cette vague d'interdiction
d'installation de Tik Tok sur les
téléphones
professionnels des fonctionnaires
fédéraux Union européenne nationaux
c'est cosmétiques et purement à usage
politique c'est de l'hygiène minimum à
avoir quand on est fonctionnaire
et pourquoi ça arrive pourquoi la vague
pourquoi le retour de vague après l'Inde
il y a quand même plusieurs mois arrive
maintenant enfin est-ce que tout ça est
utile d'une manière ou d'une autre
techniquement politiquement que ça soit
corrélé aux actions menées depuis la fin
de l'année dernière par les États-Unis
en matière justement d'embargo sur les
technologies et que ça soit corrélé à
une montée en tension sinon américaine
sur les technologies c'est évident
qu'il y est un risque réel par rapport
au secret pour dire les choses autrement
on s'espionne assez
largement entre alliés on s'espionne
encore plus en traversée à voir entrée
ennemi donc par définition le fait que
des fonctionnaires de sécurité puisqu'on
départ ça concernait les personnalités
militaires les personnes les agences de
renseignement américain et autres
et par la suite effectivement les
fonctionnaires de manière générale le
fait qu'on ait à se préoccuper
effectivement de la sécurité de l'État
ça me paraît une chose naturelle et
minimale est-ce que ce sera efficace
c'est ce que les gens suivront et
outrepasseront pas effectivement les
directives qui leur sont donnés dans ces
domaines c'est une vraie question
mais je crois que inéluctablement du
fait de l'absence de transparence que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
sur la captation des données sur l'usage
qui peut en être fait tant d'un point de
vue politique d'un point de vue
d'espionnage que d'un point de vue de
contrôle des populations je crois
effectivement j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire dans l'article on m'interroger sur
la question je crois que ce n'est que le
début
vous parlez de contrôle des populations
et là on vous parle des fonctionnaires à
Bruxelles ils sont 30000 à tout casser
ceux à qui on a interdit l'installation
donc est-ce que c'est une goutte d'eau
[Musique]
inutile ou est-ce que c'est un signal à
envoyer pour d'autres que quid des
grandes entreprises je vais vous dire
quid de la personne qui dans une
entreprise sous-traitante en armement
n'a pas conscience de l'importance de
son des données qu'elle a dans son
téléphone et qui n'en a pas l'obligation
à ce stade qui n'en a pas d'interdiction
pardon à ce genre j'entends bien
sachez sachez que de la même manière
puisqu'on parlait d'histoire de la même
manière qu'on a pu lorsqu'on a
déclassifié les archives soviétiques
voir à quel point l'Union soviétique
était paranoïaque de chacune des actions
qui pouvaient être menées en Occident de
la même manière on a pu le voir aux
États-Unis avec les actions contre
Facebook et d'autres sociétés elles sont
extraordinairement vigilantes à l'image
qu'elle donne d'elle-même il y a
quelques temps je donnais une conférence
à une croissance plus qui est
l'association des entreprises
technologiques donc en développement en
France et j'entendais quelqu'un me dire
mais vous savez avec l'argent dont
dispose ses sociétés je précise qu'il y
a deux ou trois ans
elle ne craignent absolument rien elles
n'ont rien à craindre Facebook en
particulier etc et on a vu que la somme
de mauvaise décision et surtout de
mauvaise presse et de mauvaises comment
dire de masse réputation qui ont pu être
générés du fait du scandale Cambridge
Analytica du fait effectivement par la
suite de l'action du 6 janvier donc aux
États-Unis enfin la aussi de coups
d'État par définition on voit bien que
ça a un impact sur les investisseurs
que l'on n'a pas cité aujourd'hui
n'oublions pas que parmi les grands
investisseurs de ces sociétés chinoises
il y a beaucoup d'Américains Alibaba
étaient fondés au départ par des fonds
américains qui ont largement financé
l'un des premiers actionnaires du plus
grand constructeur chinois automobile
BYD biwyd C Warren Buffett
sans parler de BlackRock et quelques
autres font américains donc il faut pas
se tromper si vous faites peur aux
investisseurs c'est pas c'est pas
simplement la peur de la presse qui
pourrait agiter les Chinois non ça va
faire des investisseurs avec la tension
qui est en train de se créer autour de
ces questions je vais vous dire
les piqûres répétées d'un insecte
peuvent être parfois plus mortels que
que le seul serpent qui viendrait
effectivement
attaquer tel ou tel donc je crois je
crois réellement que ça a un impact en
termes d'image en termes de réputation
et que et que ce caractère sulfureux
pourrait avoir effectivement un terme la
capacité pourquoi pas à décider des
investisseurs à se reporter plutôt vers
d'autres
émergents dans ces domaines des réseaux
sociaux ou dans ces domaines des
services plutôt que de continuer à faire
confiance à TikTok donc ça ne mange pas
de pain techniquement parce qu'il est
bon qu'un commissaire européen ou son
directeur de cabinet
ne puisse pas être comment dire un jour
par une puissance ou une autre menacée
qu'on lui fasse du chantage sur le fait
de croiser des choses qui dans son
téléphone et mais la force symbolique
est peut-être encore plus je pense que
les deux sont importants d'accord madame
oui je voudrais revenir sur les textes
européens desa et le projet de règlement
sur l'intelligence artificielle vous
nous avez dit tout dépendra de la
manière dont ce texte seront appliqués
certes mais cela dépend aussi un petit
peu de ce qu'il y a dans ces textes je
ne suis pas que ça soit des déclarations
de bonnes intentions encore faut-il qui
qu'on y trouve des dispositifs
propices à l'encadrement de ces
plateformes et notamment dans un seul
but de protéger
l'utilisateur hier devant notre
commission d'enquête un intervenant a
fait part d'une proposition d'air qui
rejoint la proposition que nous avons
fait avec mes collègues de la commission
des affaires européennes sur ces textes
qui est en quelque sorte un principe de
safety by design c'est-à-dire la mise
sur le marché d'une application ou une
application qui change en cours de route
d'algorithmes etc pour une nouvelle
utilisation l'obligation comme pour un
médicament qu'on mettrait sur le marché
de Béné ficier d'expérimentation étant
donné pour mesurer les effets négatifs
ou les effets indésirables comme on dit
pour les médicaments est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une une proposition qui
permettrait
à l'instar de ce qui nous a été dit hier
d'améliorer sensiblement cette
protection quelle que soit la plateforme
en particulier chinoise bien sûr puisque
tel est l'objet aussi de notre
commission d'enquête
à l'évidence oui il est important
d'avoir des études d'impact des analyses
d'impact concernant ces technologies
sur le texte de Laia il y a eu un
reproche qui lui a souvent été fait et
qui fait l'objet de grands débats au
sein des communautés scientifiques sur
le fait de savoir effectivement si on
peut réguler de façon véritablement
efficace des systèmes dont même les
scientifiques qui les développent ne
sont pas toujours à même de savoir par
avance les réponses qu'ils vont donner
ce qui est ça m'a été souvent confirmé
par des scientifiques de haut niveau
dans le domaine de l'IA donc par
définition c'est vrai que c'est complexe
mais qu'il faille éviter comme on a pu
le voir peut-être avez-vous vu puisqu'on
a beaucoup parlé de tchat GBT récemment
vous avez vu qu'il y a quelques années
Microsoft avait tenté de mettre en place
un système quasiment équivalent qui
avait été qui s'était interrompue nette
suite au fait qu'on avait pu le
détourner pour lui faire dire des
horreurs racistes
enfin bon misogy enfin beaucoup de
choses qui étaient inacceptables et donc
on a vu le soin qui a été mis en place
par les équipes d'Open pour évidemment
éviter que ça ne se reproduise c'est pas
parfait il y a des moyens de cont et on
est capable de lui jusqu'à une perte de
naissance on était capable de lui faire
dire la manière de créer du napalm sous
prétexte effectivement de de préciser
que c'était quelque chose qui me
rappelait des choses que j'avais pu
entendre est-ce que tu pourrais faire en
sorte de me remettre dans cette
situation et en gros de contourner les
règles qui se donnent au départ ça a été
vrai quelque temps immédiatement quand
ils se sont rendus compte de ça ils ont
pu le faire donc je dirais que là dessus
la capacité que nous aurons à faire en
sorte que les systèmes ne deviennent pas
toxiques je pense que l'expertise
puisqu'en fait quand on parle de cela je
parlais tout à l'heure de la notion de
transparence qualifiée au niveau du code
l'expertise dans ces domaines est en
train de monter en puissance il faudra
évidemment que l'État au travers de
d'acteurs je dirais tiers mais aussi au
travers certainement d'une compétence
interne je pense qu'il est important de
développer la compétence interne de
l'État dans ces domaines l'État au sens
large ces agences
ensemble de son action mais mais je
crois que
on va vers ça mais je répète ça ne doit
pas nous distraire du fait de savoir si
en focalisant trop près la loupe
on n'oublie pas effectivement le
excusez-moi l'expression globale picture
l'image générale le paysage général et
vers où nous souhaitons-nous aller
c'est-à-dire est-ce que plus encore
qu'effectivement limité les dérives
toxiques de tel ou tel système
d'intelligence artificielle nous devons
pas plutôt essayer de développer les
nôtres
pour ne pas être dépendant voilà
absolument et c'est et je crains que en
ne focalisant comme ça souvent était le
cas et je ne dis pas que c'est le cas
bien sûr évidemment pas dans la question
que nous nous posons aujourd'hui mais ça
trop souvent été le cas on a dit en gros
on a pris comme vous savez on parle de
monopole naturel par exemple dans le
domaine économique on a fini par penser
qu'il y avait des technologies
naturelles non non technologie sont ce
que nous en faisons ou pas et nous avons
laissé la bride sur le coup de ces
sociétés pendant là les deux dernières
décennies en termes de régulation sur
les données en essayant maintenant de
resserrer un peu la vis il n'est que
temps de nous poser véritablement la
question est-ce que ces technologies ne
sont pas en train de nous faire un
courir un risque démocratique je le
citais avec
un risque démocratique un risque de
d'instabilité risque de polarisation de
ne plus avoir de d'action commune y
compris de vérités communes et on le
voit avec l'intelligence artificielle
tous les jours
avec des systèmes effectivement qui
deviennent à ce point toxique que on ne
sait même pas ce qui pourra apparaître
comme la vérité dans les temps à venir
auprès d'une population qui verra une
chose qui est vraie et qui dira mais non
c'est forcément faux c'est forcément
indiffé donc voyez il y a une je dirais
il y a une capacité et je parlais tout à
l'heure de contrôle politique il y a une
démocratisation dans le plus mauvais
sens du terme des outils de manipulation
de masse dont on a pu voir je
rappellerai pour mémoire que Prigogine
dont on parle le temps sur Wagner c'est
un mercenaire enfin c'est une armée
privée d'un côté mais c'est aussi une
armée de trolls de ferme atrol
c'est-à-dire de d'outils des
informations de masse avec son agence
ira international agency donc par
définition ce sont ces outils là que
nous devons effectivement essayer de
combattre dans les temps à venir et si
on laisse s'installer le même nouvel
Harry a fait d'ailleurs un acte récent
dans le dans le économistes où il disait
que lia pourrait hacker le code de nos
civilisations c'est à dire en gros se
substituer à la formation des opinions
la formation des
je dirais des cultures dans les temps à
venir d'une manière qui est
véritablement inquiétante parce qu'elle
serait détenue par une poignée de
personnes qui auraient un pouvoir infini
sur des milliards de centaines de
millions de milliards de personnes donc
je crois effectivement que c'est aussi
ça se à ce travail là que nous devons
nous appeler dans les temps à venir
y a-t-il d'autres demandes de prise de
parole chers collègues
et oui sur un porteur
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
bien que je ne l'ai pas entendu je vous
remercie pour votre exposé et je vous
prie de la vouloir m'excuser parce que
j'ai eu hier soir un imprévu qui m'a
empêché d'être à l'heure aujourd'hui
donc je risque de vous poser une
question qui a déjà été posée
[Musique]
nous sommes en guerre
c'est pas nous nous disons nous passons
notre temps à dire que nous ne sommes
pas en guerre contre les régimes
autoritaires que surtout il faut pas
considérer qu'on est en guerre ça
n'empêche pas monsieur Poutine de dire
qu'il est en guerre contre nous qui est
non seulement gain contre l'Ukraine mais
contre le temps contre l'Occident des
cadences etc de s'allier à Monsieur Ji
INPI qui lui dit que leur accord est
total indéfini etc et qui apporte le
même jugement de valeur sur le déclin
d'Occident que que Poutine sans parler
d'un certain nombre d'autres
à Pyongyang ou à Téhéran
donc il y a même si je caricature en
disant nous sommes Agay et ils sont
guère il y a un véritable affrontement
aujourd'hui entre les sociétés
démocratiques et les sociétés
autoritaires ou totalitaires
le désavantage de Dieu de prétendre que
nous ne sommes pas en guerre par rapport
à ceux qui pensent qu'ils sont en guerre
c'est qu'évidemment on a moins tendance
à se préparer et à faire cette guerre
que les autres nous imposent c'est le
cas de toute évidence dans le domaine
cyber
on l'a vu on l'a vu et c'est assez
étonnant mais peut-être je me trompe de
ne pas en avoir tiré les leçons on l'a
vu sur des événements majeurs qui ont
été élections de Trump le brexit un
certain nombre de choses on l'a vu en ce
qui nous concerne de façon beaucoup plus
directe avec ce qui est en train de se
passer en Afrique ce qui est en train de
se passer en Afrique qui est quand même
assez stupéfiant dans un pays dans un
certain nombre de pays qui sont des pays
francophones ou les Français sont je
dirais pas comme chez eux mais je veux
dire depuis des années et des années
sont à l'aise ont souvent avaient des
rapports
le proximité avec les gouvernements et
où vous parliez tout à l'heure de
Prigogine une
armée de trolls
comment dire d'une d'une organisation
[Musique]
pas avec pas des normes moyens même s'il
y a derrière les moyens de la Russie en
quelques mois a réussi à travers les
réseaux sociaux à balayer à chasser à
faire chasser un peu il y avait pas que
ça mais notamment vers chasser les
défensés de Burkina Faso du Mali etc
sans et peut-être c'était ma première
question sans apparemment que nous y
réagissions de la moindre façon sur les
mêmes sur le même de sur les mêmes
médias sur les mêmes technologies en
tout cas d'une façon si réaction il y a
eu elle a été totalement improductive
c'est assez surprenant
il semble la compréhension semble venir
sur notamment sur la loi de
programmation militaire que nous allons
étudier ou la cyberguerre et pour la
première fois enfin ça fait des années
des années que de l'autre côté ceci
existe on a l'impression d'un retard
considérable donc c'est c'est ma
première ma première question
comment je ne sais pas s'il y avait
partie des appartements où vous êtes
l'Institut de la souveraineté numérique
je suppose que vous avez dû vous occuper
aussi de de ces questions comment est-ce
que vous analysez cela et quels sont
aujourd'hui les les les remèdes à c'est
ma première question moi j'ai une
question qui est un petit peu aussi dans
le dans le même sens
concerne l'absence de symétrie qui n'est
pas seulement une absence de symétrie
sur le plan économique je
précise que je veux dire les plateformes
occidentales essentiellement américaines
et que patron occidentale sont tout
interdites en Chine et en Russie de
l'autre côté la Russie la Chine ne se
prive pas d'intervenir
l'argamanu sur les plateformes
occidentales elles en ont personne ne
les en empêche et en plus elle commence
à mettre en place elle-même des
plateformes comme Tik Tok qui
[Musique]
dans mon esprit et susceptible d'être
beaucoup plus à terme qu'aujourd'hui
mais bon mais à terme une autre façon de
déstabiliser les démocraties comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure
[Musique]
on a l'impression que là-dessus
également c'est un sujet différent mais
assez proche que là-dessus également il
n'y a pas de réaction que on ne se
préoccupe pas de cette absence de
symétrie
donc ma
question c'est est-ce que vous faites la
même analyse et comment réagir
c'est une question qui devrait
évidemment des développements importants
je vais tenter je vais tenter d'abord le
problème des plateformes de réseaux
sociaux ça a été souvent évoqué et le
fait que et en particulier c'est vrai on
a pu le voir beaucoup avec Twitter c'est
qu'on y favorise le la confrontation
plutôt que la réflexion ce qui était
évident pour un format comme Twitter qui
par définition est un format alors les
psychologues par l'informat classique
c'est à dire en gros qui tient introduit
la notion de détruire
et donc par définition le format de la
raison qui demande plus de temps qui
demande plus de modération ne passe pas
donc pensez que pour excusez-moi là
encore les anglicismes le fact checking
permettra de contredire ce qui se
produit sur des réseaux sociaux de façon
manipulée vous parliez effectivement des
officines qui peuvent être utilisés par
tel ou tel bonigine mais pas que pour
développer effectivement une activité
sachant la facilité avec laquelle
aujourd'hui on peut créer alors je vous
donne un chiffre que peu de gens
connaissent par trimestre par trimestre
Anthony bois donc trois mois vous avez
Facebook qui efface 1 milliards je dis
bien milliards de faux comptes
oui oui c'est plus de 6 milliards
l'année dernière donc sur l'année donc
par définition créer des fauconstes ça
peut être fait industriellement par les
officines avec quelques développeurs et
et des équipes réduites à l'échelle
effectivement de centaines de millions
de comptes qui vont se répandre entre
eux et qui vont donner l'impression d'un
phénomène de masse ça porte là aussi
excusez-moi des termes effectivement
dans ce métier on parle d'astrotterping
c'est à dire la sensation de faire
naître un mouvement spontané de
d'opinion là où il n'y a rien
et donc aujourd'hui la question qui se
pose et ça nous ramène à ce que nous
évoquions sur le modèle économique de
ces plateformes basées sur les données
personnelles aujourd'hui le problème qui
se pose c'est aux États-Unis vous savez
il y a le
chose quasi soi-disant quasi religieuse
qui s'appelle le premier amendement
liberté de la parole fréquemment speech
mais aujourd'hui rien ne dit que nous on
doit avoir non pas le Freedom speech
mais le Freedom bridge c'est à dire la
capacité d'amplification de ce qui était
auparavant un propos de café ou de
comptoir qui maintenant devient audible
et visible par des centaines voire des
milliards d'individus ça c'est
inacceptable or par définition face à
des plateformes opaque dont on évoquait
le cas pour la plupart et en particulier
pour Tik Tok la capacité d'amplification
de propos à des fins de propagande est
infini
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est sur
cette capacité d'amplification des
messages de haine des messages
politiques de propagande que nous devons
nous concentrer la réponse je dirais
bloc à bloc de raison versus n ne marche
pas
il nous faut réduire la capacité cons
ces réseaux
de système de propagande dont je précise
que maintenant ils peuvent être
entièrement gérés par des systèmes
intelligence artificielle qui donne
l'impression de répondre aux gens de
façon parfaitement articulée là où en
fait il n'y a personne en face je
précise que snapchat voyez le dernier en
date ça date de cette semaine vient
d'intégrer un système de réponse par
l'intelligence artificielle à ses
abonnés alors je sais pas s'il utilise
ce chat ou une autre maison mais donc
par définition je pense que il nous faut
prendre le problème c'est le cas de le
dire à la racine c'est-à-dire essayer de
comprendre comment ces mécanismes se
diversifient et existent par le fait
qu'il n'est pas besoin de présenter une
quelconque d'identité évidemment pour
développer des centaines de millions de
faux comptes qui n'est enfin qui a pas
de barrage à l'entrée et que du fait de
cette absence de barrage à l'entrée on a
une automatisation de la parole de
propagande une industrialisation et je
le disais une démocratisation dans le
plus mauvais sens du terme de ces
systèmes de propagande comme jamais
auparavant
donc c'est vrai des États mais c'est
vrai aussi effectivement d'officine
particulière extrémiste et autres qui
peuvent exister donc je crois qu'il faut
être conscient des mécanismes et que
considérer que on doit être dans une
mécanisme de logique face à une
dispositif ou en face de vous vous
n'avez même pas une personne mais vous
avez une intelligence artificielle qui
n'en a rien à faire que vous essayez
entre guillemets de lui faire rendre
gorge ça ne marchera jamais je crois
qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui avoir une
autre attitude sur le fondement de ces
plateformes et sur le fait effectivement
que cette exploitation forcenait de la
donnée à des fins publicitaires mais à
des fins aussi de manipulation de
propagande d'ingérence est une chose sur
laquelle nous devrons revenir
inéluctablement
et quand on fait effectivement de dire
on est face à des pays qui ont été
largement l'objet de manipulation je
précise que des manipulations existent
ici elles ont existé aux États-Unis elle
commence à exister dans tous les pays du
monde par définition effectivement notre
porosité est lié même
à les liée d'une part au principe
démocratique d'ouverture vous citiez
effectivement les plateformes sur lequel
les Russes ou les Chinois peuvent
interagir librement en Europe aux
États-Unis je crois effectivement que il
y a aussi une forme de naïveté
technologique sur laquelle nous devrons
revenir
il y en aurait eu mais on vous remercie
infiniment pour la précision et la
densité de vos propos et une comment
dire une concentration de citation de
Mao au mètre carré qu'on a pas de risque
là voilà ni voyait pas une tendance
personnelle non non bien sûr merci merci
infiniment monsieur